[Musik]
zdf heute live herzlich willkommen
die kanzlerin hat gesprächsbedarf
deshalb hat sie sich heute einem
interview gestellt mit dem zdf heute
journal
und es ist nicht das erste sondern es
ist das dritte interview dass die
kanzlerin innerhalb von kurzer zeit gibt
nach ard und rtl ist nun also das zdf
heute journal das format in dem die
kanzlerin rede und antwort steht hier
sehen wir es heute am späten vormittag
war es glaube ich oder um die
mittagszeit nie früher nachmittag so mit
der kollegin marietta slomka vom heute
journal
so weit die vorbereitungen warum macht
die kanzlerin das warum so viele
interviews in so kurzer zeit der lock
down wurde verlängert am vergangenen
mittwoch bis zum siebten märz und daran
gibt es viel kritik
vielleicht ja auch von euch oder von
ihnen zu hause wie immer freuen wir uns
über eure und ihre fragen wie immer in
die kommentare oder wenn er oder sie die
zdf- heute- app nutzt bitte an zdf heute
live punkt zdf.de wir analysieren
dieses interview mit einer virologin und
einem politikwissenschaftler und ihnen
und euch heute abend in dieser sendung
und beginnen aber mit seiner roeser sie
ist bundesvorsitzende der jungen
unternehmer in berlin schönen guten
abend frau rosa schön dass sie uns
zugeschaltet sind
einen schönen guten abend frau rosa dann
schauen wir uns mal direkt an was die
kanzlerin im interview zum thema
öffnungs perspektiven gesagt hat und da
ist es ja so dass wir auf eine 7 tages
incidents von 50 zu steuern dann ist
neuerdings 35 angestrebt und was dann
möglich ist das schauen wir uns mal für
die nächsten öffnungs schritt nach dem
einzelhandel müssen wir schauen ob wir
stabil unter 35 bleiben oder bei 35
bleiben wenn die gesundheitsämter die
kontrolle haben werden die zahlen sogar
runtergehen
aber lassen wir die 35 es kommt keine
neue zahl jetzt dazu
solange eine minute muss sie noch das
erklären
und wenn wir den eröffnungs geschäfte
gemacht haben und wir haben einen
infektionsschutz also zwei wochen lang
stabil unter 35 dann können wir den
nächsten schritt ins auge fassen und
schon mal den geschäften sagen woher
wenn das landesweit 35 sind kann man in
absprache mit seinen nachbarländern
schon die geschäfte öffnen selbst wenn
noch nicht alle bundesländer das haben
das gibt öffnungs und wir haben dann
drei stränge im grunde noch wir haben
die schulen in den höheren jahrgängen
berufsschulen unis wir haben die
privaten kontakte als zweiten strang wie
viel mit wie viel menschen darf ich mich
treffen und wir haben einen dritten
strang das sind im grunde die
kultureinrichtungen kinos theatergruppen
sport und dann auch die restaurants und
eines tages die hotels der froser ganz
kurz ich binde den chat schon mal an
dieser stelle ein andrea es schreibt im
youtube chad danke zdf team interessant
und images mit blumen daumen hoch und
einem smiley mit maske vielen dank liebe
userin andrea es schon mal dafür und
jetzt die erste frage an sie frau rosa
was haben sie denn gedacht wie haben sie
denn aus unternehmerinnen sicht reagiert
als sie gehört haben dass 35 das neue 50
ist ja also für mich persönlich und für
uns als junge unternehmer ist es absolut
nicht nachvollziehbar
die frage die wir uns wirklich stellen
müssen ist was erleben wir denn dann im
nächsten monat wenn jetzt auf einmal die
zielmarke von 50 auf 35 runter gesetzt
wird
auf was müssen wir uns einstellen wir
als unternehmer und das sage ich klar
ganz klar und deutlich wir brauchen
klare verbindliche aussagen und vor
allem nach all den anstrengungen die wir
unternommen haben fehlt uns wirklich die
stichhaltige begründung dafür und es
erzählt auch die erklärung
beispielsweise warum jetzt friseure
schon eröffnen dürfen egal welche
inzidenz vor ort herrscht und und gerade
aus der exklusive öffnungen sind
wirklich aus meiner sicht willkürlich
getroffene entscheidungen
ähnlich schreibt ein user namens pvv
über youtube zuerst 50 935 es ist
absolut sorry schäbig schreibt dieser
nutzer nun muss man sagen dass diese 35
nicht ganz aus der luft gegriffen ist
die steht im infektionsschutzgesetz §
28a schon seit november wurde darauf
hingewiesen dass man ab diesem
schwellenwert von 35 breit angelegte
schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen soll um das
infektionsgeschehen schnell abzusenken
und wenn man darunter liegt eben nicht
so weit reichende maßnahmen trotzdem
haben natürlich viele reagiert wie sie
und nun ist natürlich auch die frage was
man sich denn stattdessen gewünscht
hätte es gab ja verschiedene pläne aus
den bundesländern von verschiedenen
parteien christian lindner hat den
sieben stufen plan der fdp
diese woche hier in dieser sendung
vorgestellt was hätten sie sich denn
gewünscht
ja also wir als familienunternehmer und
junge unternehmer und auch unsere
mitarbeiter wir alle hatten wirklich
gehofft dass uns die regierung eine
perspektive gibt anstatt neue zielmarke
auszurufen
weil die zunehmend besseren zahlen die
wir ja beobachten können die wir in den
regionen erleben haben uns wirklich alle
hoffnungen gemacht dass wir bald wieder
die geschlossenen branchen und betriebe
öffnen können und dass er wieder voll
wirtschaften können und das hat hätte
die regierung reicht durch einen
systemischen stufenplan erreichen können
was wir jetzt sehen ist dass wir uns an
in instanzen orientieren und aus meiner
sicht aus unserer sicht der jungen
unternehmer müssten wir viel mehr
kriterien in das auge in den fokus
nehmen das heißt einerseits natürlich
klar die höhe der intention der
identischen zahl dann aber auch die
auslastung der intensivstation wie sieht
es da aus wie kommen wir mit den
impfungen der risikogruppen voran
und vor allem wir müssen uns die
landkreise genau anschauen ob
eröffnungen möglich sind oder nicht das
hätte ich mir tatsächlich erhofft und da
appelliere ich tatsächlich auch an die
politik schnellstmöglich so ein
stufenplan den wir ja sie haben es
bereits genannt
der fdp vorgelegt bekommen haben auch in
abbau von einzelnen bundesländern dass
wir tatsächlich jetzt auch einen
konkreten plan vorgelegt bekommen
nun ist es so dass ganz aktuell
niedersachsen beschlossen hat schon ab
morgen wieder blumenläden und
gartencenter zu öffnen was wiederum die
freie und hansestadt hamburg auf die
palme bringt weil die sagen das
befördert genau das was wir nicht
wollten die einen machen auf die anderen
machen noch nicht auf die leute werden
von einem landkreis in den anderen
fahren und das kann ja auch eigentlich
für unternehmer nicht nett sein weil der
baden-württembergische blumenhändler
muss morgen noch zu lassen der in
niedersachsen macht auf wo bleibt da die
fairness also ja man muss flexibel
reagieren aber einheitliche regeln
braucht die wirtschaft doch auch oder
also wir müssen tatsächlich regional
agieren das heißt wir haben jetzt
natürlich erlebt wir haben jetzt eine
exklusive öffnung für beispielsweise
friseursalons was aus meiner unserer
sicht völlig willkürlich getroffen wurde
und es zeigt vor allem auch dass die das
corona den regierenden politikern immer
mehr über den kopf wächst weil wir
erleben eine angst eine angst vor den
mutanten über die man jetzt spricht und
diese angst führt zu willkür und das
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen für spielt
auch tatsächlich vertrauen der
wirtschaft in die politik und auch die
hoffnung die wir haben und deswegen
brauchen wir eine klare perspektive
wir müssen regional schauen weil es
bringt nichts wenn die hohe zahlen in
hamburg beispielsweise haben und
niedrige zahlen hier bei mir in
stuttgart wo ich sitze dass wir gleich
agieren wir müssen tatsächlich regional
öffnung strategien verfolgen das ist aus
meiner aus unserer sicht der beste und
richtige weg sie als unternehmerin
schauen natürlich auch international was
machen die anderen wenn man da nach
südkorea zum beispiel schaut oder
nachteil waren die viel weniger
datenschutzbedenken haben als wir aber
dafür auch viel weniger einschränkungen
würden sie sagen das wäre was was ich
mir für deutschland auch wünschen dürfte
würde werft mehr datenschutz über bord
las dafür mehr leute wieder zurück in
ihre freiheit gehen können aber dafür
machen wir eher digitaler nachverfolgung
wäre das eine idee
ja also ich sag mal so wir hätten uns
glaube ich alle mehr erhofft von der
korona ab und von der nachverfolgung
dass es auch tatsächlich funktioniert
aber das erleben wir ja faktisch nicht
was aus meiner und unserer sicht
wirklich was ist brauch ist was ich
gerade eben schon angesprochen habe ist
dieser regionale stufenplan mit blick
auf die landkreise wir brauchen vor
allem wir müssen gucken dass wir schnell
impfen wir brauchen schnelle impfungen
weil das ist wirklich eine perspektive
die wir auch haben wir brauchen auch die
nachverfolgung gesundheitsämtern muss
besser werden und wir müssen auch
wirklich die bestehenden maßnahmen
kontrollieren was momentan nicht
konsequent gemacht wird und wir müssen
vor allem darüber diskutieren und auch
eine strategie entwickeln wie wir
dauerhaft mit dem virus leben können ich
glaube darauf müssen wir uns einstellen
und da braucht es natürlich eine
funktionierende corona app zur
nachverfolgung aber auch alle anderen
parameter müssen hier mit berücksichtigt
werden dann greifen wir bei einem auf
weil sie den gerade auch angesprochen
haben das thema impfen auch dazu hat
sich die kanzlerin geäußert und auf die
kritische frage von marietta slomka ob
man da nicht einfach viel verbaselt hat
sagt die kanzlerin nein das war im
wesentlichen ein kommunikationsproblem
schau mal rein
ich will gar nicht so herum reden es
gibt eine enttäuschung
und vielleicht hat diese enttäuschung
etwas damit zu tun dass ich es erstmal
faszinierend fand dafür überhaupt einen
impfstoff haben nach weniger als einem
jahr das ist eine riesenleistung damit
konnte man nicht rechnen
und dann wir nicht ausreichend darauf
hingewiesen haben dass am anfang nicht
für jeden gleich der impfstoff da ist
man hat sehr große zentren gebaut die
erwartung war im märz wäre diese zentren
ausgelastet sein ende märz april da
werden wir mühe haben alles zu verhelfen
aber die ersten wochen sind jetzt knapp
und das haben vielleicht manche menschen
auch anders sehen sie das auch so im
wesentlichen kann man froh sein dass es
den impfstoff gibt es wurde halt nur
eine erwartungen geweckt die dann nicht
gehalten werden konnte oder würden sie
sagen dann da ist auch bei der
beschaffung sehr sehr viel schief
gelaufen und wir als wirtschaft hängen
daran dass geimpft wird weil sonst
kommen wir nicht aus aus dieser pandemie
ja also natürlich können wir uns
glücklich schätzen dass
dies so schnell ein impfstoff entwickelt
wurde und dass wir ihn haben
aber es ist natürlich fatal wenn wir
beobachten wie die impfstrategie
tatsächlich vollzogen wird
beziehungsweise dass es sehr schleppend
anläuft
da hätten wir uns von seiten der
unternehmer aber auch natürlich als
bürgerin erwartet dass es viel schneller
geht weil das ist wirklich unsere
hoffnung schnell zu impfen wieder in die
sagen wir neue normalität dazu kommen
dass auch die wirtschaft wieder voll
öffnen kann damit wir wieder
wirtschaften können das ist ja das
wichtigste in dem moment und da hätte
ich mir schon eine gut durchdachte
impfstrategie aber auch eine gute test
strategie gewünscht es wir sind hinten
dran es wurden fehler gemacht aber die
müssen jetzt behoben werden ich glaube
das haben auch die regierenden erkannt
von daher hoffe ich dass jetzt endlich
hier auch mal der turbo knopf gedrückt
wird
apropos turbo knopf ich möchte mir gerne
eine sache mit ihnen gemeinsam anschauen
sie haben auf instagram über ihren kanal
olaf scholz eine mahnung geschickt
vielleicht können wir uns die hier
gerade angucken hier hinten ist sie
lieber @ olaf scholz die jungen
unternehmer schicken ihnen heute die
erste mahnung viele unternehmen warten
immer noch auf die versprochenen
november und dezember hilfen und stehen
unverschuldet vor dem nichts ist zwar
gut dass herr altmaier und sie nun nach
steuern wollen aber das kommt fünf nach
zwölf und sind vor allem eins wieder nur
ankündigungen wie man es dreht mission
fällt herr scholz frau rosa wie ist denn
der stand in sachen hilfen thema turbo
knopf
na ja also ich muss sagen viele
unternehmer sind wirklich frustriert und
verärgert und das war auch wirklich der
grund warum wir gesagt haben wir müssen
jetzt auch etwas unternehmen wir müssen
lauter werden weil die november und
dezember hilfen die sind bei vielen
unternehmen noch gar nicht angekommen
jetzt seit dieser woche mittwoch kann
man ja endlich die überbrückungshilfe
drei dann auch beantragen
aber es wurde so gibt es wurden so große
versprechen gemacht ende letzten jahres
im november das schnell geholfen wird
unbürokratisch und so viele unternehmer
stehen wirklich mit dem rücken zu der
und warten auf die auszahlung der gelder
wissen nicht mehr wie sie ihre kosten
noch tragen sollen und da ist wirklich
große enttäuschung großer frust und
deswegen haben wir tatsächlich auch
diese mahnung ausgestellt um wirklich
hier olaf scholz und das
finanzministerium wachzurütteln und ich
muss auch sagen dass viele unternehmer
verärgert sind weil das selbstlob der
regierung was die finanziellen hilfen
betrifft können wir einfach nicht mehr
ertragen es gibt kein wort von frau
merkel dazu dass die hilfen bisher
wirklich miserabel organisiert wurden
und dass selbst wie gesagt die november
hilfen jetzt und wir haben
februar noch nicht überall angekommen
sind es gibt keine andeutung dazu wie
denn diese grottenschlechte
zusammenarbeit muss man sich wirklich
nennen zwischen wirtschafts- und
finanzministerium künftig verbessert
werden soll
und wir als unternehmer wir hoffen
wirklich und appellieren an die politik
dass endlich schnell ausgezahlt wird
weil viele unternehmen während es nicht
mehr lange durchhalten
das wäre meine letzte frage die ich gern
noch an sie richten würde nicole
landauer schreibt über facebook alles
auf sofort irgendwann sind wir auf dem
stand eines entwicklungslandes alles auf
haben sie gerade schon gesagt das ist
nicht ihre meinung sie sagen auch mal
muss langsam öffnen aber eben mit einer
guten perspektive
aber wie ist denn die lage der deutschen
wirtschaft aus ihrer sicht ist es um die
deutschen wirtschaft bestellt
wir müssen uns sorgen machen also wie
wir sehen dadurch zwang schließungen
wurden viele branchen geschlossen seit
monaten gibt es da keine umsätze mehr
viele mitarbeiter befinden sich in
kurzarbeit und wir müssen um auch alles
später mal bezahlen zu können um die
haushalts kassen wieder zu füllen mit
steuergelder um firmen vor der insolvenz
zu schützen müssen wir erwirtschaften
wir müssen den branchen den
einzelunternehmen die chance geben unter
gut mit jene konzepten zu öffnen und wir
haben es doch im ersten block dann
wirklich bewiesen
es wurde viel geld investiert von
unternehmen in plexiglas scheiben in
luftreiniger es wurden hygiene kann
entwickelt und darauf brauchen wir auch
wir brauchen auch wirklich vertrauen in
die politik und in die einzelnen
bürgerinnen und bürger dass wir das
gemeinsam schaffen also wir müssen öffne
natürlich unter berücksichtigung dieser
hygiene konzepte und was vor ort
tatsächlich möglich ist um auch die
gesundheit der einzelnen menschen zu
schützen
aber wir müssen die wirtschaft jetzt
endlich wieder ans laufen bringen weil
ansonsten werden viele unternehmen
diesen zweiten lockdown nicht überleben
sagt sanna röser die bundesvorsitzende
der jungen unternehmer dankeschön frau
rosa dass sie heute abend mit in der
sendung waren dankeschön und jetzt gehen
wir noch ein bisschen weiter südlich von
stuttgart weiter nach münchen zu frau
professor ulrike protzer der direktorin
des instituts für virologie an der tu
münchen und am helmholtz zentrum in
münchen schönen guten abend frau
professor protzer guten abend frau
professor protzer sie haben das mit
verfolgt diese woche sie haben
mitverfolgt dass der look down
verlängert wird
bis zum siebten märz sie haben auch die
neuorientierung an der 35 mitbekommen
was ist ihre einschätzung als virologin
zu diesen neuen schritten
ich glaube man hat dann vorsichtig
reagiert angesichts dessen dass wir
schon auf die 50 zu laufen und wir haben
es gerade gehört regionalliga teilweise
schon unter den 50 sind ein bisschen
vielleicht im hinterkopf diese neuen
varianten haben von denen man ja etwas
verunsichert ist vielleicht noch nicht
so ganz genau weiß wie man sie
einschätzt aber ich würde auch sagen es
war eine etwas vorsichtigere aktion
dann werfen wir mal einen blick auf die
mutation die kanzlerin hat sich auch
dazu heute im interview mit dem zdf
geäußert
jetzt haben wir die mutation wir wissen
nicht wie sie wirkt deshalb müssen wir
besonders aufmerksam sein
aber es hängt jetzt von uns und klugen
öffnungs schritten ab ob wir ohne eine
große ausgeprägte dritte welle durch die
pandemie kommen oder ob wir zu
unvorsichtig sind und dann doch
vielleicht wieder steigende fallzahlen
was ich vermeiden möchte was können sie
uns sagen über die mutation
man unterscheidet zwei typen der
mutation hat er der wie wir sagen
varianten
das eine ist diese britische variante
die ist ansteckender da gibt es
eigentlich sehr sehr gute daten ob sie
schwerer krank macht ist noch nicht ganz
endgültig geklärt vielleicht ein ganz
klein bisschen aber sie breitet sich
schneller aus und das ist das was man
den großbritannien in vielen anderen
ländern gesehen hat und das kann
natürlich sich schon auf die zahlen
auswirken
aber sie kann sich nur ausbreiten wenn
wir wir helfen dabei sich auszubreiten
ich hab mal gesagt wir tragen das virus
spazieren und wir tragen natürlich dass
wildtiere spazieren wir tragen genauso
die varianten spazieren also wenn wir
vermeiden dass das virus sich ausbreitet
dann kann auch die variante sich nicht
ausbreiten
das hängt dann sehr viel am einzelnen
und der konsequenz der hygiene konzepte
habe und dann gibt es eine andere gruppe
von varianten da gehört die
südafrikanische und auch die
brasilianische dazu die haben eine
vielleicht etwas verminderte reaktion
auf unsere immunantwort das heißt
unserem 100 ford kann diese variante
nicht mehr so gut kontrollieren und
deswegen kann es wenn man abfallen der
antikörpertiter hat zum beispiel oder ja
vielleicht auch mal eine impfung nicht
ganz so gut anschlägt dann doch zu einer
infektion kommen also sowieso zwei
unterschiedliche szenarien die durch
diese varianten hervorgerufen werden
können
nun erleben wir ja dass sie
unterschiedlich im moment sich schon
ausbreiten weil man weiß in tirol ist es
vor allem die südafrikanische variante
in tschechien ist es vor allem die
britische variante korrigieren sie mich
wenn da andere mutationen im umlauf sind
nun hat man vor allem die große angst
wenn man die schulen öffnet und das ist
ja der nächste schritt der angegangen
werden soll
zumindest flächendeckend einzelne
maßnahmen mal außen vor
dazu schreibt tobias weber über youtube
nun erstmal die schulen öffnen und dann
abwarten jetzt einfach wieder alles auf
einmal öffnen wird fast schon mit
sicherheit zu wieder steigenden
aktions zahlen was wissen sie über die
infektiosität der mutationen unter
kindern da weiß man noch nicht so
richtig viel darüber weil die meisten
länder im moment natürlich ihre schulen
zu haben
was man aber weiß dass diese britische
variante so nicht so sehr bei den super
spreading events jetzt mehr übertragen
wird sondern wirklich in der eins zu
eins übertragung und es natürlich schon
die übertragung die in den schulen
relevant ist
das andere ist ja mehr so bei partys
oder großveranstaltungen und ich denke
trotzdem dass man die schulen öffnen
kann ich glaube wir haben inzwischen
gute konzepte wie man damit umgehen kann
man kann wenn es einen fall in der
schule gibt dann die kinder einfach fünf
tage nach hause schicken nach fünf tagen
kann man alle testen die die negativ
sind können wieder zurück in die schule
ich glaube da gibt es gute konzepte wie
man das machen kann
wir wissen auch dass schüler kein
problem haben masken zu tragen
also auch da kann man wenn wenn die halt
enger beieinander sitzen im klassenraum
sicherlich übertragungen dadurch gut
über gut verhindern
und natürlich kann man auch
klassenzimmer lüften und wenn es dann
gar nicht geht dann kann man sogar über
luftreiniger oder sowas nachdenken
wir würden euch und sie gerne an dieser
stelle nochmal ein bisschen anregen mit
zu diskutieren und fragen zu stellen
sehr gerne nochmal an die eingeblendete
e-mail-adresse zdf heute - live at
zdf.de oder über facebook oder über
youtube sowie das zb zwei userin gemacht
haben die in zwei fragen stellen die in
dieselbe richtung gehen und zwar fragt
ein user namens tag über youtube was ist
wenn geimpfte die mutter zu dass die das
mutierte virus bekommen so und er jp
schreibt über youtube wann könnte man
sich nach einer überstandenen corona
infektion erneut mit den bekannten
verschiedenen varianten infizieren also
in die richtung was kann passieren wenn
ich schon mal infiziert war oder wenn
ich geimpft war kann man dann trotzdem
die neuen mutationen bekommen
das ist genau so ein bisschen die
bedenken die man hat bei der
südafrikanischen bei der brasilianischen
variante weil die sich durch diese
antikörper die unser immunsystem bildet
nicht so gut wie wir sagen
neutralisieren also abfangen lassen ist
die gefahr wenn ich nicht so hohe antike
geht antikörpertiter habe dass ich dann
die infektion bekommen kann und das kann
natürlich einmal sein wenn ich eine
infektion hatte die schon ein bisschen
her ist man sieht das so nach vier bis
sechs monaten die antikörper die das
schon ab fallen gerade wenn es leichte
infektionen waren also die schweren die
haben typischerweise ziemlich gute
antikörpertiter aber die mit relativ
wenigen symptomen
da sind die antikörper titer nicht so
hoch da ist die gefahr gegeben und
natürlich auch wenn ich jetzt eine
impfung bekommen habe und vielleicht
erst im ersten impfschutz bekommen
ersten dosis der impfung bekommen habe
aber die zweite noch nicht also auch da
meine antikörpertiter einfach noch nicht
so gut sind und dann nicht ausreichend
diese variante abzufangen und gegen sie
vielleicht schon ausreichend hat das
normale virus abzufangen
ich würde sie gerne einbeziehen eine
kleine expertendiskussion die sich hier
in unserem youtube chad gerade entfaltet
vielleicht können wir mal ganz kurz auf
meinem monitor umschalten und zwar fragt
dann nämlich dark side hessen was ist
eine mutation und dankenswerter weise
wird die frage dann vom user just right
thing beantwortet mit eine veränderung
des erbguts und somit der eigenschaften
von zellen
frau professor protzer ist das richtig
erklärt oder gibt es da noch etwas
hinzuzufügen oder zu korrigieren was ist
eine mutation also schon ziemlich gut es
ist eine veränderung des erbgutes in dem
fall aber nicht von zellen sondern von
viren
viren vermehren sich und bei der
vermehrung machen die sogenannte
polymerase die also dass die die ab
information des virus zusammenbauen die
machen fehler und dadurch entstehen
mutationen und das was was bei jedem
virus bei der vermehrung immer passiert
die frage ist nur hat diese mutationen
die da entsteht irgendeine konsequenz
verändert die eine aminosäure und
erlaubt diese veränderung dem virus dann
an
eigenschaften zu erwerben und was man
weiß zum beispiel bei der britischen
variante ist eine typische veränderung
einer aminosäure dafür verantwortlich
dass das virus besser an seinen rezeptor
bindet und damit infektiöser wird und
bei der südafrikanischen ist es eine
andere aminosäure veränderung die eben
die bindung von antikörpern
verschlechtert also im prinzip etwas was
bei jedem virus in der firmierung immer
passiert nämlich eine eine veränderung
einzelner nukleinsäuren im erbgut und
dann die frage macht es was für die
eigenschaft aus und wenn es das tut dann
sagen wir das ist eine variante die uns
gedanken macht also im englischen dann
eine very end of concern ein thema das
uns vielleicht auch helfen könnte als
eines von vielen instrumenten aus dieser
pandemie rauszukommen sind die tests und
dazu schauen wir noch mal kurz in das
interview von heute 1
wir haben uns entschieden alle gemeinsam
wir wollen wissen wie wirksam sind sie
denn wir müssen auch aufpassen dass
diese tests die man selber machen kann
dann nicht zum schluss vielleicht nur
eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 60 prozent
haben da wir uns alle nicht geholfen
aber es gibt ja längst studien die
zeigen dass auch diese ganz normalen
schnelltest die professionell angewendet
werden dass man die zu hause auch selbst
machen kann dann braucht man sich das
stäbchen weil sie nicht bis oben ins
gehirn was für kinder und mit mir an
schulen decken wirklich keine gute
möglichkeit ist und sicherlich auch dazu
beiträgt dass ein pflegeheim viel
weniger getestet wurde weil es eben auch
unangenehm ist dann kann das auch selber
und genauso zuverlässig das wissen wir
jetzt seit herbst aber immer noch haben
wir keine zulassung
nein das stimmt auch so nicht wir haben
eine die hersteller stellen einen antrag
und sie haben einen antrag gestellt
darauf dass es durch das medizinische
personal durchgeführt werden kann
wir haben den test gemacht also
modellversuche mit lehrern und der
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat in
der verordnung gesagt alle dürfen es
selber machen die in einer kritischen
infrastruktur oder lehrer und erzieher
sind das heißt dort kann der schnelltest
heute selbst angewendet werden entweder
von jemandem der sich ein video
angeguckt hat der erfahrung gesammelt
hat dass ich schuld hat muss aber kein
keine besondere schulung sein sondern
man kann das mit einem mitgelieferten
video vom hersteller
selbermachen professor protzer sind
diese selbsttests ein game changer und
aus ihrer sicht sicher genug um sie
flächendeckend einzusetzen
ich glaube schon dass man diese tests
breit einsetzen kann wenn man die nutzer
darauf hinweist dass diese tests keine
100 prozentige sicherheit bieten wir
wissen bei jedem dass das so das
material was da reingeht dessen qualität
ist natürlich entscheidend also auf gut
neudeutsch roggisch in rabat wenn ich
also einen schlechten abstrich mache
dann kann der test so gut sein wie er
will dann kann er einfach nichts
entdecken die abstrich qualität ist
wichtig und der abstrich ist oft
unangenehm aber er ist halt auch nur
dann wirklich sensitiv und empfindlich
wenn man eben in diesem nach
nasen-rachen-raum auch rein kommt ganz
egal welchen test ich hinten dranhängen
man sieht dann die verschiedenen tester
anschaut sorry ich wollte nur eine
aktion an roman kann dass er sie würden
auch sagen dass man dass man das selber
machen kann also ja es ist unangenehm
aber es würde reichen sich ein
möglicherweise entsprechendes video
vorher anzugucken und dann kann man das
selber machen oder würden sie sagen nein
das ist immer noch besser in den händen
von medizinisch geschultem personal
nein man kann das selber machen man
sollte wissen wie man diesen abstrich
macht das so kann man sich in videos
anschauen das kann man sich auch in
natürlich piktogrammen anschauen
aber man kann der server panda gibt es
auch studien dazu man muss es nur schon
richtig machen also nur einmal kurz
vorne in die nase rein das gibt dann
keine richtig gute qualität vom abstrich
aber man kann das selber machen und auch
der test hintendran der ist nicht so
kompliziert auch dem kann man auf jeden
fall selber machen
man muss nur wissen diese ganzen schnell
teste haben eine verminderte wie wir
sagen sensitivität als empfindlichkeit
ich entdecke damit nicht hundert prozent
aller infektionen ich entdecke damit 60
bis 70 prozent der infektionen und die
anderen die entdecke ich mich also wenn
ich einen negativen test habe ist es
halt einfach keine hundertprozentige
sicherheit
ich kann nicht ganz sicher sagen ich
lasse jetzt die die maske weg und lasse
alles bleiben die gute nachricht ist
besser 70 entdecken als keinen entdecken
also machen diese testen natürlich schon
sinn und sie machen vor allem dann sinn
wenn jemand symptome hat also zum
beispiel so typisch kind will morgens in
die schule hat aber schnupfen und
bislang schmerzen
da ist es besser ich machte den test und
entdecke eben zumindest 70 prozent der
infektionen oder vielleicht wenn ich
glück habe sogar 80 prozent der
infektionen und übersee doch relativ
weniger als wenn ich gar kein test
machen man muss halt immer diese diese
einschränkung einfach mit wissen hätten
wir das nicht schon viel früher machen
müssen das ist ja schon gemacht worden
die schnellste sind ja schon relativ
breit in der anwendung also zum beispiel
vor altersheimen wo dann jeder besucher
der hineingeht oder auch an jeder
mitarbeiter der hineingeht getestet wird
aber auch da es halt immer wichtig auch
wenn ich ins altersheim rein gehe und
meint es negativ bin ich mir halt nur zu
60 70 prozent sicher aber eben nicht zu
100 prozent also ich darf deswegen jetzt
nicht meine maske abziehen und die oma
die ich lange nicht gesehen haben ohne
maske dann setzt sich die trotzdem noch
einem risiko aus aber insgesamt zu
testen ist natürlich besser als nicht zu
testen und gemacht wird es schon seit
einer ganzen weile
ich möchte an der stelle gerne noch auf
unseren zdf check hinweisen denen man
auf unserer homepage sich anschauen kann
warum die kanzlerin bei den schnelltests
oder die bundesregierung auch erstmal
gezögert hat haben wir da beschrieben
und auch beschrieben welche
studienergebnisse ist schon zum thema
schnelltests gibt und wo vor und
nachteile sind das also an dieser stelle
noch erwähnt und noch eine frage
liebe frau protz alois comparis schreibt
über youtube sehr geehrte frau protz
wäre es nicht sinnvoll sich ebenfalls
sehr stark auf die entwicklung von
medikamenten zu konzentrieren und nicht
nur auf impfungen da hat er absolut
recht
ich glaube wir brauchen beides die
impfung wird natürlich die ausbreitung
des virus verhindern und wird auch
verhindern dass menschen ins krankenhaus
kommen das sieht man übrigens sehr sehr
schön wenn man sich die daten in israel
an guckt da ist die rate derer die über
60 jahre als sind wo er schon viele gift
sind und die ins krankenhaus kommen
deutlich abgesunken wohingegen die rate
der jüngeren die noch nicht geimpft sind
eben nicht abgesunken ist und weiterhin
noch leicht ansteigt da sieht man
wirklich den effekt den die impfung hat
aber es verhindert natürlich nicht zu
hundert prozent jede infektion
die impfungen sind super wirksam gerade
die em-arena impfstoffe mit 95 prozent
die verhindern 19 von 20 infektionen
aber eine findet trotzdem statt die
vector impfstoffe die sind nicht ganz so
effizient die verhindern 65 prozent dh
zwei werden verhindert eine findet
trotzdem statt und für diese die
trotzdem stattfinden brauche ich
natürlich auch medikamente also eines so
sich nur auf eines zu fokussieren macht
keinen sinn ich glaube wir brauchen
beides vielen dank frau professor ulrike
protzer nach münchen für diese
einschätzungen heute abend hier bei zdf
heute live dankeschön fürs mitmachen
eine frage lieber user abdul von und zu
rachman werden wir leider nicht
beantworten können weder frau professor
protzer noch herr rudolf korte der uns
jetzt zugeschaltet ist ebenfalls in
diesem stream nämlich wann wird es
wieder werden wie vor corona professor
karl rudolf korte politikwissenschaftler
der universität duisburg-essen diese
frage werden auch sie nicht beantworten
können dafür aber viele andere nämlich
zum beispiel warum die kanzlerin sich
innerhalb von so kurzer zeit bei so
vielen sendern zum interview erklärt ist
der erklärungsbedarf offensichtlich so
groß ja der ist ziemlich groß aber es
ungewöhnlich für die kanzlerin das
stimmt sie ist ja erklärungs arme
pragmatikerin normalerweise und ist
jetzt in die kommunikations offensive
gegangen
aber politik zeigt sich von der besten
seite nämlich erklären
begründen rechtfertigen das sind die
wichtigsten instrumente die die politik
hat um uns in einer freiheitlichen
demokratie auch wenn sie mich fragen was
hätte ich anders gemacht ich habe
gestern auf zwei dinge hingewiesen dass
eine ist der umgang mit den masken die
alltags masken haben uns über die zeit
als wir noch nicht genug medizinische
hatten hinweg geholfen und da war ich am
anfang zu zögerlich
ja lieber professor korte da ist eben
die kanzlerin ins wort gefallen was aber
nicht ihre schuld ist sondern ein
technischer fehler hier bei uns in der
regie sorry for that ich hoffe sie
können mich noch hören weil ich sie
glaube ich gerade nicht hören kann
aber ich versuche mal trotzdem nochmal
meine frage zu stellen
sie haben gerade ausgeführt dass man in
diesen zeiten viel erklären muss und die
bürger mitnehmen muss nun hat man sich
am mittwoch getroffen und neue maßnahmen
beschlossen
zum einen verlängerungen des lok downs
und gleichzeitig neue maßnahmen ist das
gut genug erklärt worden und sind dass
maßnahmen die die menschen nachdem sie
so lange schon in dieser pandemie
mitmachen auch mitgehen können
es gibt nichts schwierigeres in dieser
zeit als die moderation von ungeduld und
in dieser phase ist die krone politik im
moment eingetreten
viele sind erschöpft und können auch
durchhalteparolen nicht mehr ertragen
andererseits ist die politik in der
situation nach wie vor entscheiden zu
müssen zwischen dem dilemma von freiheit
und gesundheit das abzuwägen bedarf
vieler erklärung auch vieler intensiver
diskussion jede diskussion ist auch
willkommen weil sie eine
auseinandersetzung ist mit
unterschiedlichen interessen die wir als
bürgerinnen und bürger ja auch haben
insofern ist das etwas positives das
nicht eine etwas anordnet und wir dem
alle einfach nur folgen sondern immer
kritischer nachfragen und es gibt
einfach phasen die nach monaten
eingetreten sind dass wir nach der
ersten erstarrung geradezu der krise der
exekutive dann doch auch in andere
phasen übergegangen sind und um selber
mit stärker einbringen auch als
bürgerinnen und bürger was wir selbst
wollen
denn das ist ja auch nicht immer
identisch mit dem was parlamentarier für
sich dann auch reklamieren und trotzdem
haben wir so viele leute in dieser
pandemie das gefühl sie werden nicht
gehört und viele sagen auch obwohl es ja
wie sie gerade sagen gar nicht stimmt
dass keine diskussion gewünscht ist das
keine eigene meinung gewünscht ist dabei
erleben wir das ja im bundestag dass die
parteien da sehr wohl sehr viel kritik
äußern und aus allen möglichen
richtungen kommt kritik was wäre dann
ein rezept für die regierung damit
umzugehen und den menschen doch zu
vermitteln gerade in diesem wahljahr
diese demokratie ist nicht gefährdet
nein wir diskutieren in der tat sehr
hart über diese maßnahmen die niemandem
leicht fallen ja in der tat sind ja die
mehrzahl der bürger noch alles
vollkommen hinter dieser entscheidung
stehen hinter dieser entscheidung sie
haben vertrauen in die korona politik
der regierungen
die große mehrheit akzeptiert ist
toleriert ist trägt es auch weiter mit
die starts frömmigkeit hat geradezu
zugenommen starts gezählt könnte man
sagen rettet politik im moment
menschenleben und verteilt auch viel
geld natürlich vielleicht zu wenig
menschen leben werden gerettet das geld
kommt zu spät an haben sie in der
sendung ja auch schon zum thema gemacht
aber wir sollten uns nicht irritieren
lassen die mehrzahl folgt zuversichtlich
gerade zu dieser politik und auch dem
aufgeklebten aufgeklärten gestus nicht
nur als untertan sondern sie versucht es
auch zu verstehen und umso einfacher ist
es aus meiner sicht dass politik auch
klar macht was sie jetzt vorhat die
parteien differenz ist ein wichtiger
punkt dabei dass also die opposition
vielleicht auch regierungsparteien
unterschiedlicher meinung sind dass dies
auch medial transportiert wird und wir
merken
man ringt um position letztlich geht es
um immer neue lage einschätzung wie
lernen wir in der krise das ist ja im
bunde das entscheidende
unter ungewissheit zu entscheiden setzt
voraus dass ich immer wieder neu mit
teile welchen wissenstand ich heute habe
den ich vor einer woche nicht hatte und
in diesem lernmodus kann politik
durchaus auch entscheidungsfähig bleiben
es hängt aber davon ab dies auch zu
erklären und nicht zu sagen wir wissen
jetzt schon etwas und können ein
masterplan daraus ableiten das wäre
absolut dass wir doch niemand abnehmen
den politiker insofern ist es auch eine
frage wie man versucht zu kommunizieren
wichtig um auch die korona politik nicht
nur zu erklären sondern auch immer
wieder zu rechtfertigen dass es
unterschiede gibt rechtfertigen auch
dass es lernfortschritte gibt die ich
umsetzen muss fehler freundlichkeit
fehler toleranz macht eine politik und
auch eine gesellschaft widerstandsfähig
aber wir müssen offen damit umgehen und
wir müssen als bürgerinnen und bürger
das auch akzeptieren unsichere wähler
wählen keine unsicheren politikern die
also permanent sage ich mache fehler
vieler fehler
das muss kann es auch nicht sein aber
ich kann erklären warum ich heute eine
entscheidung revidieren muss die ich vor
einer woche noch richtig fand weil wir
eine anderen wissenstand haben wir haben
einen unsichtbaren gegner und lernen
dazu und genau das sagt angela merkel
heute im zdf interview gemacht stichwort
fehler freundlichkeit die kanzlerin im
gespräch mit marietta slomka darüber was
man denn vielleicht in der rückschau
hätte anders machen sollen wenn sie mich
fragen was hätte ich anders gemacht ich
habe gestern auf zwei dinge hingewiesen
dass eine ist der umgang mit den masken
die alltags masken haben uns über die
zeit als wir noch nicht genug
medizinische hatten hinweg geholfen und
dabei ich am anfang zu zögerlich
das hat sich dann gezeigt dass das
wichtig war und das zweite war darauf
bin ich gestern auch eingegangen dass
wir im rückblick natürlich im herbst zu
zögerlich angegangen sind ich habe
damals kein gutes gefühl gehabt aber ich
habe die entscheidung mitgetragen und
deshalb ist es mir jetzt so wichtig wo
wir wieder an dem punkt sind dass wir in
die kontrollierbarkeit und
nachverfolgbarkeit der kontakte kommen
dass sie jetzt richtig handeln und nicht
zu früh zeitig öffnen um dann zu erleben
dass wir wieder hoch gehen in den zahlen
denn wir sehen wie lange man dann
braucht um wieder runterzukommen
da herr professor korte aus ihrer sicht
kein zeichen von schwäche
sondern ein zeichen von stärke zu sagen
ja im rückblick hätte man es so und so
machen können aber wir wussten es nicht
besser ja man kann aus fehlern lernen
und das ist eben auch zu transportieren
zu übersetzen
und dass es da nicht unfähigkeit sondern
es erstmal unwissenheit und dass man das
versucht mit anderen zu revidieren ist
teil des entscheidungsprozesses der
natürlich einmal dokumentiert dass sie
noch disziplinierung macht besitzt fast
schon eine art pastorale macht die sie
versucht auszuüben in diesem kreis der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und von mal zu mal
die ministerpräsidenten dann ihr auch
folgend oft nicht spontan sondern
manchmal auch erst beim nächsten treffen
aber insgesamt selbst sie sich als
corona italien damit durch aber sie ist
in einer der klassischen rolle finde ich
sie beschreibt immer als einzelfall
entscheidung politikerin wie wir sie
kennen situations orientiert und auch in
der regel nur wirklichkeiten sie kann
nicht in der regel formulieren die
möglichkeiten aussehen und das wäre im
moment zusätzlich wichtig zuversicht
über möglichkeiten uns zu vermitteln
dieses negativ darauf warten wir noch
ich bleibe an dem wort corona titanen
erhängen und auch deshalb weil ich sehe
dass hier auf youtube im z
eine kleine nachfolgediskussion
entspinnt ihr schreibt johannes kyrle
danke die merkel soll abdanken ich
möchte herrn söder als kanzler darauf
gibt es auch ein paar reaktionen zum
beispiel von einem user namens rush hour
der schreibt ich hätte es friedrich merz
gegönnt
bleiben wir mal bei hans müller
professor korte der 70 ja wenn man das
so sagen kann quasi auch ein bisschen in
der rolle des corona titanen denn der
glückliche zufall will es dass er gerade
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist und
jedes mal quasi umsonst publicity
bekommt weil dann neben der kanzlerin
auf dem podium sitzen und die neuen
corona maßnahmen erklärt inwiefern wird
ihm das in die hände spielen was die
nachfolge von angela
merkel angeht es wirkt im moment wie
eine corona prämie dass er einfach
sichtbar ist präsent ist und dass er an
bestimmten entscheidungs und
kommunikationsstil pflegt der bei einem
teil der bevölkerung gut ankommt das ist
so eine entschiedenheit prosa es ist so
eine gewisse zähigkeit mit der er
formuliert es ist ja ein ansager gestus
dass er weiß was er macht und ein stück
weit ist es auch mit angst versuchen
solidarität in der gesellschaft für die
bayerische gesellschaft zu unterstützen
das ist nicht so angelegt wie der
gegenpart von laschet im prinzip der auf
kooperative führung setzt er auf
selbstwirksamkeit setzt der mehr laviert
intensiver erklärt und abwägt und daran
die bürger auch teilhaben lässt also
zwei unterschiedliche kooperations und
führungsstile die miteinander ringen die
nicht mehrheitsfähig sind beide insofern
werden wir auch sehen wie die union sich
zwischen diesen beiden spielen
entscheidet das werden sie im frühjahr
in aller ruhe und abwägung machen es
gibt keine eile zu einem
kanzlerkandidaten man muss formal auch
überhaupt keinen bestimmen
wir müssen als bürger am ende wissen
welche partei für uns die
zukunftsperspektive besten anbietet und
durchaus mit welchen personen
aber das amt des kanzlerkandidaten ist
ein ehrenvolles amt das höchste was eine
partei vergeben kann aber es war an der
geschichte der bundesrepublik auch das
amt was praktisch am erfolglosesten
parteien aus der opposition heraus haben
wir einen kanzlerkandidaten ein einziges
mal in über 70 jahren gewählt schröder
war das damals insofern kann man sich
also bewerben und sonnen im licht aber
die chancen dass das zu was führt sind
nicht sehr groß das wird einige
userinnen und user tief treffen die sich
hier auf einem kanzler habeck freuen
ja wir haben ja eine sondersituation
diesem jahr
wir haben erstmals historisch eine
bundestagswahl ohne titelverteidigerin
das setzt die chancen für union für
grüne und für spd in dem startlinie auf
gleich
nicht auf ungleich insofern haben sie
ganz andere chancen in der
auseinandersetzung sich mobilisierend
wechselseitig vor uns wählern und
wählerinnen zu profilieren und das
begünstigt auch natürlich die grünen in
einer koalition von einer grünen ampel
beispielsweise eine
regierungsverantwortung nicht nur zu
überleben sondern vielleicht auch die
kanzlerschaft stellen zu können aber für
die grünen geht es auch dass sie nicht
gezwungen sind eine kanzlerkandidaten
zwischen frau berbalk und herrn beck
selbst zu entscheiden
es macht die partei das hält sie in der
neugierde geradezu dass wir das wissen
wollen aber so eine tante struktur noch
zumal wenn sie so professionell einig
auftritt wie sie das gemacht seit vielen
jahren wird am ende auch mobilisieren
für die eigenen anhänger ohne uns zu
verraten werden kanzlerkandidat wäre
insofern haben wir eine neue formation
die interessant zu beobachten wäre ich
weiß nicht ob es so kommt aber wir haben
eine union kandidaten
wir haben einen spd-kandidaten der
benannt ist mit scholz und vielleicht
zwei die im tandem darum ringen am
besten zu mobilisieren und neue formate
der macht hybride formate geradezu
ausprägen in ausnahme zeiten mit viel
corona kreativität
apropos corona kreativität die zdf
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer kennen sie
natürlich von den wahlabenden als
experten an der seite von bettina
schausten
wir sind gespannt ob wir sie dann damit
maske und abstand zu zweit in einem
unter pandemie bedingungen gut
aufgestellten wahlstudio zu sehen und
was überhaupt am wahlabend möglich sein
wird vielleicht können sie dazu ein
bisschen schon was sagen wenn es dazu
schon was zu sagen gibt und auf jeden
fall möchte ich gerne von ihnen wissen
was sie glauben wie dieser wahlkampf in
verschiedenen bundesländern und auch in
der bundestagswahl eben für einen
verlauf nehmen wird in zeiten dieser
pandemie denn da ist ja auch für die
parteien alles anders dieses jahr ja das
stimmt wir haben einmal eine rückkehr
inneren an die lange wahlnacht eine
komplette nacht wird bei der us wahl bei
der ich auch als experte mit dabei war
und auch bettina schausten ja die
moderatorin war
und das ging auch mit masken bevor man
dann sich hinsetzte aber außerhalb des
jetzt haben alle masken getragen das war
so und alle paar stunden wurde bei jedem
auch temperatur gemessen so dass das
schon eindruck hatte man war sehr gut
überprüft mit allem und durch allem und
ich nehme an so wird das auch jetzt sein
jetzt wird in stuttgart jahr sein ich
gehört habe immer in dem
bevölkerungsreichsten land kommt das
hauptstudio des zdf dann zum aufbau und
dann gibt es natürlich schaltung nach
mainz gleichermaßen da gibt es auch ein
studio ein set aber die sendung wird
gefahren wie das so heiß offenbar aus
stuttgart aber ich bin da ganz
optimistisch dass das funktioniert in
den bewährten regeln und natürlich steht
man auf mehr abstand als sonst auch das
ist klar aber zur bundestagswahl in der
tat wir haben also die besonderheit dass
wir keine titelverteidiger diesmal haben
also sind wir als deutsche schon bereit
für eine für ein männliche kanzlerin
könnte man sagen nach all den jahren das
ist die große frage
wir haben eine besonderheit die
ungewöhnlich ist nach der langen
adenauer zeit war einwände wunsch nach
der kohl zeit nach 16 jahren ein großer
wende wurde dieser ist im moment nicht
messbar ist es auch nicht gut
vorstellbar dass er bis september noch
eintritt auch eine ungewöhnliche
konstellation
und die dritte haben sie konkret
angesprochen eine distanz demokratie in
der wir leben alle formate der
mobilisierung sind auf die logik des
sozialen ausgerichtet meinungsbildung
entwickelt sich im gespräch mit anderen
wo sind die anderen
wir sind einzig wir sind allein wir
haben nur distanz wir können also unsere
meinungsbildung gar nicht als
gruppenbildung ausbringen
auch das verändert jede art von
mobilisierung so dass wir nicht viel
wissen aus der wahlkampf forschen wohin
das führt insofern beobachten wie im
moment
retro elemente plakate blühen auf in
einer größenordnung wie sie sonst nicht
mehr
antworten sind es werden einzelne zettel
wieder verteilt in die haushalte so weit
man sich den ehren kann zaun gespräche
alles neue formate aber ich rechne
durchaus damit die erste testfall ist
jetzt stuttgart und mainz dass insgesamt
die politische mitte profitiert im
superwahljahr weil die extreme im moment
mit eingefrorenen werden nicht
profitieren in keiner weise weil die afd
keine zukunfts angebote offenbar
präsentiert so kroner politik zum
vorsorge statt wie es weitergehen kann
und die afg hat auch ihren weg gemacht
damit das ästhetisch mit zu kritisieren
dieses establishment ist aber nun bemüht
uns zu retten im eigentlichen sinne
deswegen kommt das auch nicht wirklich
an und insofern glaube ich dass ich die
mitte stärker ausprägt als wir das
bislang vermutlich erwarten aber sie
sehr stabil bleibt war insgesamt am ende
eine im september wie einige impfte
republik haben werden
die präzise fragt wie der vorsorge stadt
der zukunft auszurichten ist der
lenkende der sorgende der schützende
start welche partei kann darauf die
beste antwort geben darum wird es am
ende gehen und sie werden das für uns
mit begleiten und wir hier von zdf heute
live werden natürlich auch mit dabei
sein wenn es um dieses superwahljahr
geht für heute abend für diesen
freitagabend danke ich ihnen ganz
herzlich professor korte fürs mitmachen
und ihnen auch natürliche userinnen und
user zu hause und an dieser stelle
nochmal darauf hingewiesen das komplette
interview mit marietta slomka und angela
merkel finden sie natürlich über youtube
und auf der zdf heute
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend und ein schönes wochenende
bis dann tschüss